it so extorted cuz you know you've been
in something as big as a big movie
franchise like The Hobbit in something
but Benedict Cumberbatch was here he was
saying that when he gets recognized he's
in Nepal filming in the port and they
recognized him from Sherlock not only
because he carries a picture around with
it but you must get bad - yeah I mean
it's not a big show it definitely yeah
it reaches parts that other yeah do you
know when someone cuts up to you if the
if this is oh here we go
yes Hobbiton yes I do oh you do yes I do
what's the difference there's a slot
there's a sort of age demographic
slightly different I think I think
usually if it's a with all respect to
anyone who is or isn't this thing I
think you if it's a female between 16
and 25 I know that's going to be
Sherlock where you don't expect where's
the oddest place you've been
recognizable how it will have far afield
we being you know kind of jungle on top
of a mountain somewhere yeah we were we
were shooting Ali in Mozambique and we
were walking through a village you know
50 miles outside of the the major city
and there was a woman washing her
clothes in the river there was no
electricity in the place and I walked by
and she said Big Willie
[Laughter]
maybe in her language it meant something
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's cubes cues are dangerous for you
cues for the toilet when you get
recognized in a queue for the toilet and
women's you know women's bathrooms you
know in theaters 'm and places like that
there's always a huge great long queue
and that is not an easy place to be
recognized because you can't you're
stuck you have to have and then other
people in the queue and then word goes
out and now you're having a conversation
with this whole key of people all the
time slowly moving towards the you know
the cabinet that's empty and then
knowing that everybody's gonna be
listening once judging you like if you
get recognized at the years ago and I
was at the urinal and it was a [ __ ] the
interval or whatever and there were two
guys and they're both clocked me I think
this is from office days you know and
and they both clocked me and look to
each other when as you got a big one
[Laughter]
women are lucky there's bond must have a
similar effect on your life I read I
rarely get recognized is fantastic but
that's yeah that is great I think I have
a sort of chameleon face so you don't
generally recognize me I can go it
pretty much anywhere not now I sit under
places of myself on the tube
[Music]
you